so today we're talking about how halo
infinite multiplayer is now live and
battlefield 2042 is a little broken on
xbox series x my name is devonte and
you're watching gamespot news
so it's xbox and halo's birthday and to
celebrate microsoft hosted a 20th
anniversary live stream and on it 343
dropped halo infinite multiplayer early
it's like christmas
rumors of an early launch had circulated
over the weekend with some fans and
industry insiders speculating that
microsoft was planning something special
for the stream halo infinite's first
season is called heroes of reach and
will run through may 2nd 2022. but
because infinite's battle pass never
expires there's no pressure to complete
it by then throughout the season players
will be able to unlock additional weapon
charms visors and even armor kits for
each of the original heroes from halo
reach you can find the halo infinite
multiplayer in the xbox store on pc and
xbox consoles on steam or in the
recently added section of game pass and
earlier on in the very nostalgic live
stream microsoft announced a six-part
documentary titled power on the
documentary series will start at the
root of the story with a ragtag team of
directx engineers trying their best to
convince executives at microsoft that a
gaming console was the right move the
documentary series will debut on
december 13th and feature a range of
current and former microsoft employees
xbox developers and more to tell their
story and after that microsoft announced
that 70 plus additional original xbox
and xbox 360 titles have been added to
the backwards compatibility library this
list includes games like the entire max
payne and fear franchises 50 cent blood
on the sand and dead or alive ultimate
just to name a few the games are
available on xbox one and xbox series x
and s and all of them support auto hdr
while many get a resolution enhancement
boost additionally fps boost has been
added for 11 of the titles added today
and 26 from the existing library the
third big piece of news was that fps
boost is launching now on xbox cloud
gaming for 33 titles including fallout 4
and fallout 76 among others moving right
along to battlefield 2042 because it's
running into some issues on xbox series
x with players reporting that the game
completely crashes their console matches
start where you can't spawn or match a
start where you can't pick a loadout
developer dice has confirmed that this
is a system level problem on microsoft's
side that is also affecting games like
fifa madden and nba 2k according to a
blog post dice will release an update on
november 17th to resolve the crashing
issues the update is optional until
november 23rd when it becomes mandatory
however players experiencing this issue
don't have to wait that long to get the
update everyone can join the xbox
insider program and opt into the omega
ring from there the update should be
made available to help improve the
experience battlefield 2042 launched
with early access and with its 10 hour
ea play trial on november 12th the
game's servers struggled with rubber
banding and persistent data errors but
the experience is generally smoother now
ahead of its official release date on
november 19th
and now let's move on to rockstar's
grand theft auto the trilogy the
definitive edition because it's back on
pc
the game was removed shortly after
launch on november 11th amid reports
that the game's holy grail files had
been discovered these files were said to
include cut content and messages from
rockstar north developers in its
announcement rockstar also pledged that
it would continue to improve the
experience on pc amid reports that the
game is struggling in some capacity so
are you planning on picking up the
trilogy on pc let me know in the
comments i'm still very mixed about the
game and we'll just i guess continue to
play san andreas on game pass
is it i just don't know
switching gears to ubisoft now because
it has announced the post-launch dlc
plan for rainbow six extraction
confirming that a sizeable amount of the
content will be completely free
extraction is getting a challenge mode
called maelstrom protocol which ubisoft
says is being designed to appeal to the
most skilled players
not me
in the mode players will fight through
nine sub-zones each featuring new more
difficult enemies than the last players
will also find their resources deplete
more quickly and the total time
available for each stage drops each
round extraction will also have crisis
events and assignments the crisis events
are limited time events featuring themed
content as well as a new operator or new
enemy to take on assignments meanwhile
are weekly modes featuring special
gameplay modifiers the veteran mode for
example removes hud limits your ammo and
allows for friendly fire the maelstrom
protocol and assignments will be
available at launch and crisis events
will come quote some time after
so now that halo multiplayer is
officially out let me know if you're
just gonna abandon all other games and
just call out of work constantly or
school and just play it
and also this is my first halo mouse and
keyboard so uh drop some tips down below
or you know if you want to just carry me
in matches that's fine too let me know
[Music]